a couple of years ago i went to a
totally normal party
it was put on by the well-muscled brain
explorer brian johnson
he held the event at this house in
venice
california billionaire patrick collison
was there and so was his smile
the guests all got together donned
bluetooth headphones and listened to
music written by an ai and performed by
american idol contestant taryn southern
oh and you could also take a whiff of an
extinct hawaiian plant because some
people who play with dna had found a way
to bring its smell back to life
[Music]
the folks who did the dna manipulation
work at ginkgo bioworks
the company is perhaps the world leader
in the field of synthetic biology
earlier this year ginkgo raised a
staggering 2.5 billion dollars on its
way to being valued at 15 billion
to find out what 2.5 billion dollars
buys you these days
i went to ginkgo's headquarters in
boston massachusetts
for it is here
[Music]
or make that here
that the company is building out a dna
super highway
[Music]
[Music]
was founded back in 2009 by several big
brains from mit
including its ceo jason kelly
the founders wanted to develop ways to
treat dna more or less like software
code you find an organism with an
interesting property
snip out the dna behind that property
and then shove the dna fragment into
something else
[Music]
the big promise behind synthetic biology
is that we'll find a new means to
harness nature and bend it to our will
we'll be able to manufacture things like
chemicals and fuels and even physical
objects in ultra efficient ways
to be clear we're also talking about
eventually getting into jurassic park
mad scientist style stuff
and this grand experiment could end up
with you being a reptile's breakfast the
core idea behind the company was inside
of every cell
every bacteria plant animal on planet
earth is digital code in the form of dna
right so it's atc's and g's
not zeros and ones like you'd see in a
computer but you can read that code with
dna sequencing and importantly you can
write that code with dna printing and
this is
like for a bionerd like me this is magic
you like literally go on a computer you
type atc
you hit print and out of machines like
in this facility or the ones next door
comes a piece of dna that's exactly what
you ordered
and then you can put that into a cell
and our idea was if you can read and
write code and you have a machine
that'll run it which is sort of how we
thought of a cell you're programming
just like you'd program a computer yeah
so ginkgo's business is basically
programmer tools so that other folks can
develop new programs for sales
this core synthetic biology principle of
treating dna like code is simple in
theory
in most cases scientists will grab the
dna they want and insert it into
something like a bacteria or yeast
then they create lots of copies of the
organisms in much the same way as we
make beer
they feed the organism's sugar and
nutrients and grow them in a vat
so i'll give you an example there was a
flower
that went extinct
in uh it was like the early 1900s in
hawaii
but before it went extinct it had gotten
collected by scientists and then stored
and it actually was at the harbor
botanical museum and so we collected
some of that sample brought it back here
to genko put it through our dna
sequencer so we read the dna code of
that extinct flower we found the part of
the dna that encoded for the scent
so we would take those 6 000 letters of
dna and move them into a bacterial
genome like e coli so how do you do that
well you have a special enzyme that
basically can find a location on the
genome it looks for a t ggs whatever one
is on the specific code it has and it
cuts
and then it opens and then you add in
those six thousand letters from the
extinct clause how did you get them well
you read them you had them on the
computer you put them in atcg hit print
and you printed a piece of synthetic dna
so now you add that into where you cut
and then you patch it up a little bit
grow the cell and instead of just doing
the normal swim around bacteria thing it
also now makes this fragrance yeah and
so we actually resurrected the scent of
this extinct flower as a project is
actually showing a few art museums to
kind of bring it back
to see some of this process in action i
went to visit sarah in one of ginkgo's
labs
okay so somebody you you've made a
microbe you've engineered it with a
specific bit of dna to give it a quality
that you're looking for and then you
guys are both making those and checking
that they're coming out right we're
testing a lot of different engineered
strains to help us build our code base
to understand which of those pieces of
dna are
are able to achieve the desired outcome
okay and so you know you've got these
cells over here
some of them have stuff on them the
white and some of them don't so i assume
the ones with the white is kind of ones
that have worked and that's what you're
looking for yeah so each of those
individual segments is a particular
engineered strain that we are trying to
isolate in order to then test downstream
the segments that have the individual
white circles which we call colonies
have successfully taken up that dna so
this would be like the beginning stage
of you get what you want and then you
kind of then you can grow it in bigger
quantities you can study it after yeah
so this is the very the very start of
that kind of pipeline
[Music]
what ginkgo really wants to do is
automate all of this
and make meddling with dna fast and
cheap
to do that you need a factory
this is perhaps the most modern dna
assembly line on the planet
molecules go in at one end of the
conveyor belt
and robots take care of all the
processes needed to refine them into
something useful
so this is a magnetic propulsion system
that has individual cuts and the robots
or the humans will load samples onto
these carts and then the system will
know which destination they need to take
them so a human comes here and puts a
sample feeds it into the exactly
there you go
and now you can press the button over
here okay
and then off it goes
[Music]
on the green robot now you can see the
green robot pick it up and we'll place
it on this second station there and this
is when the yellow robot will come into
play
the little yellow robot will remove some
of the samples add controls in their
place
the tube rack then goes to the next
processing station which is a centrifuge
workshop here okay spin it around
essentially to try to remove bubbles or
anything that might have formed during
shipping of the samples okay
i think our sample's off again
so now now we're sealing the plate and
it can go over the rest of the process
it all ends with an incredibly
sophisticated trash can
these specialized trash work cells have
these specialized cuts that can weigh
the amount of trash that is in each of
these bags to know when they are full
and finally the robots can actually
place the trash at random positions
around the bag to make sure that they're
not always stacking up in the center
making very large towers that can
eventually break the system and does a
human have to take this out at the end
this is the last step where the human is
still in the loop
step forward one helpful tv host
[Music]
i remember around 2008
it was getting easier a bit to
manipulate dna and we could see where
things were going but people were
already saying
in a few years we're going to be you
will program a cell to make a chair and
we won't have chair factories
we'll just grow them and and so how much
of that vision do you still believe in
and how close are we to this idea that
you know we're gonna um just be making
kind of like fantastic new things
out of biology
i think it's all coming yeah you do yeah
the reason is i cannot emphasize this
enough people take biology massively for
granted yeah
every other engineering field was
designed by humans from the bottom up
we know every little bolt in that ford
car every little semi you know
like gate in that semiconductor chip
from intel
well biology is
ridiculously advanced and we're just
entering the era of being able to
program it to do new things we know it's
capable of big things yeah the only
limit is human understanding to be able
to program it but we know if we learn
it can do this stuff because it's
already doing it it's making our food
it's cleaning our water it's making the
air you know we're made out of it
and
the one magical feature of it and it is
a miracle
is it's programmable because inside of
it is digital code that we can as humans
read and write
ginkgo does go after some weird stuff
[Music]
this dog for example used to be a teacup
poodle just last week
and clearly people here really do dream
of doing things like resurrecting the
dinosaurs
but as with any new technology i wanted
to know how synthetic biology would
benefit me
like right now
and so i took what we'll call the blood
elevator express
a couple floors down to another startup
motif food works
motif is sort of a research and
development company for food
it uses synthetic biology to make food
taste
better today i'm here to eat a burger
only no cow was involved
motif teamed with ginkgo to take the dna
code for hemoglobin
plop it into a yeast
and then grow what amounts to a vat of
faux blood
this fella here is adding the blood to
some soy
throwing in some seasonings
and then
voila
[Music]
thank you so much
well should we try it well it's still
hot absolutely that's the best way okay
it's good
it's burglary for sure and it has that
like the i mean on the char and all that
your chart yeah the bite quality is much
better i would say that old generations
of plant-based meat
the first bite you might get this crust
on the outside you like to see here yep
but the second bite would be more mushy
the inside would not have texture so
look at
all the effort i mean that pretty much
looks like what you might see in a
burger you notice all the pieces the way
it crumbles the other thing i noticed is
there's definitely that umami kind of uh
well note our ingredient we call hemami
and it's essentially
the molecule in the muscle of a cow that
makes beef red it makes it give you that
beautiful sear me bloody flavor it
catalyzes a whole bunch of the chemistry
in there and that is an amazing piece of
technology that ginkgo bioworks created
for us
ginkgo was able to look at 300 different
muscle proteins from different species
mini sperm whales one that comes to mind
um tuna
pork chicken a whole series of different
birds and they're already sequined so it
wasn't like we took any animal material
yeah when they did the sequences it was
it was for
specific muscle protein a class called
myoglobin okay
ginkgo got us the ability to look at all
the different properties stability taste
flavor color
and then once we honed in on the ones we
wanted we asked them to optimize the
yeast to kind of turn that into a mini
factory so that we can make it and so we
can have the great taste
of beef
without using any animals
to put a fine symbolic point on how all
of this stuff gets made i felt it
essential to go to a nearby brewery with
jason
i thought being in a brewery was yeah
ideal right
they use yeast
but like no commercial beer today is
made with like genetic engineered cells
have you ever had a non-alcoholic beer
it tastes like [ __ ] yeah well that's
because it's getting rid of the alcohol
you're like pulling off all the flavor
components and so could you make a yeast
that doesn't produce much alcohol it
gives you all the taste so you end up
with like a alcohol free beer that
actually tastes good
brewing is an industry that has like
biology so intrinsic to it that it's
actually an opportunity to like figure
that out and do it correctly
we've worked on the brewing industry i
think it's going to come around very
soon actually yeah oh thank you oh look
at that thanks
cheers and teased yeah to yeast
ah it's good
i wanted to go back just like a little
bit where did you grow up i grew up in
florida in florida yeah yeah south
florida and what was your family as like
kind of science family or we weren't
like a family of phd i was i was the
first person to get a phd yeah yeah they
um but were you even like in high school
and everything besides your thing yeah
yeah the uh yeah i honestly i think what
it was was
i was you know
12 13 years old when jurassic park came
out yeah and i was like i was a big
sci-fi nerd i was reading books all you
know like i've read all those cricket
books i love that stuff you know uh and
i i think i fell in love with it then
[Music]
what kid wouldn't dream of playing god
to that end i wanted to know when we'd
get past perfumes and fast food blood
and get to the good stuff the freaky
stuff
when i was talking with the guys that
helped make the show this was one of the
lingering questions that we still
weren't sure about you know i can get
the enzyme to cut and paste dna i can
get it to
make the the myoglobin right right but
then why can't you grow
an arm is what we kept talking about
it's like michael you put in the code
for the arm then if you could put in the
code for the protein why can't you do
the whole thing
so it's a great question and this is
like me when i got to mit yeah i'm like
i thought i would be making arms or
something you know right
and
the short answer is
we don't understand
the specific sequence of dna
how it affects the cell
it's just because we didn't design cells
and they're complicated
and so
if you put in some new dna that was like
i think this dna will make an arm it
just wouldn't
right and but it might make like you
know some other deranged thing
but it's like salamanders the freaking
salamander grows arms but humans don't
you know like and so it's like a it's
just a a programming problem between
here and there but like we know the
substrate is capable of it
obviously everyone thinks about climate
change all the time like you know as far
as and i don't want to give people false
hope on any stuff but something that's
just gobbling why can't we just gobble
carbon and yeah [ __ ] out happiness on
the other side you know where's
okay so
so the project we're doing we have a 100
million dollar joint venture with bare
crop science yeah okay you know
synthetic nitrogen fertilizer okay the
way you make it you basically pull
nitrogen out of the air you're basically
going to take that nitrogen you're going
to combine it with hydrogen to make
ammonia which is fertilizer
where do you get the hydrogen oh burning
natural gas right okay so you burn
natural gas about like i think it's like
four percent global greenhouse gas is
going to freaking fertilizer hey we get
to eat you know right like we need
fertilizer right okay well there are
certain crops like soybeans that don't
need much fertilizer why
they have microbes in their roots
they're like literally pulling nitrogen
out of the air nature doing all the work
it's like you plant a legume and it it
re-fertilizes the soil so we can go find
the code that produces fertilizer for
crops in
in soybeans
we can take microbes that are friendly
with corn
install that code and then a business
that bear already has you do a seed
treatment you basically coat the seed in
those bacteria and when you plant it
they grow along with it and they produce
fertilizer for the crop yeah that's the
project so so that's one where if you
actually succeeded not only is it a 70
billion dollar market it's a four
percent global greenhouse gas reduction
yeah no that's cool
but no uh but nothing's just out there
gobbling co2 out of the air yet well
trees you know then yeah
like that's an amazing
amazing machine and it is like when you
look flying on an airplane and you look
out the window what do you see
right like that is real scale okay none
of this crap like our auto plants and
chip fabs it's a joke you know right the
only real scale on the planet that's
actually making anything is biology the
only thing we're good at making is co2
and [ __ ] things up you know right
like like you know
[Music]
to jason's point humans do have a
tendency to run amok when given new toys
and this could all go bad
jurassic park bad
that said synthetic biology is the area
of technology that excites me the most
the stuff bubbling away in these jars
and flowing through these tubes
represents our best shot at fixing many
of the messes we've made and it doing so
many other things better in the future
it's certainly not communing with nature
in any traditional sense
but it's an area where humans can meld
science and creativity in previously
unimaginable ways
in dna
there is hope
you